did you know it's possible to build a
dynamic website in minutes without the
use of heavyweight tools I'll show you
how right now
first let's grab a basic bootstrap
template let's go to start bootstrap
calm scroll the will scroll down and
let's grab this one I really like this
portfolio template so I'll just click
download and I will open it up and unzip
it now that I've unzipped it I can just
drag the index to Chrome and this is
what it looks like so it's got a basic
introduction it's got the portfolio
elements which I can click on to enlarge
and it has an About section and it has a
contact form unfortunately this contact
form won't work because it's PHP and we
don't want to have to mess with PHP we'd
rather just have it work without PHP so
there's a great tool for us to be able
to use dynamic forms on the web without
any hassle at all it's called power Keio
let's go to power first we're going to
create an account
now we'll click sign up and we're going
to choose from these different dynamic
elements we're going to choose contact
form and we could use all these
different site builders but we're just
using my HTML here so we can click the
tutorial
all right and here is a quick tutorial
so what we're going to do is we're going
to add this script power j/s to our HTML
at the bottom of the body so let's just
open up index we're gonna use a text
editor I personally like atom which is a
free text editor from github and we'll
scroll to the bottom of the body and we
will just paste in power dot J is next
what we're going to do is we're going to
add an HTML element it's the power
contact form so let's go ahead and grab
that and let's go ahead and put that in
the contact form section so here's a
contact section what I'll do is I'll
just delete everything out of this
actually yeah I'll delete everything out
of the contact section except for the
container oh I'll keep the container
just paste it in here and save it and
now let's see if we can add one more
thing while we're here I really like to
have a Twitter tool and there's a
Twitter feed tool here too so basically
we've already got power J s so all we
need to do is add a Twitter feed dative
I'm not sure that this will look great
but basically I'm just gonna put it
right underneath the contact form for
the purpose of demonstration so now we
can save this and we can go to a tool
called bit balloon fifth balloon comm
makes for really easy deployment except
you have to have the website maximized
in order to be able to drag and drop it
here so now I'm just going to take my
entire folder this whole start bootstrap
template freelancer thing and I'm going
to drag it here it's gonna give me a
warning about us having dynamic pay
is the PHP don't worry about that
because remember we over wrote the PHP
with the power contact form
and it's done so it'll give us a funny
little name here and we can click on it
and just open up the website and this is
live on the internet we'll scroll down
we'll see here our contact form that we
can edit inline using power let's just
change the let's change the background
color just to show you how real-time
this is ugly purple all right and then
we can just save it and close it and
then here's the Twitter feed and right
now it's powered IO well let's change it
to me so we'll just do content and I'll
just change this to OC yeah or better
yet let's do free code can save it you
can see this is a live page on the
internet with a working contact form
I'll show you it works submit it and
these are my Twitter this is my full
Twitter feed which I can click on and it
will take me to actual tweets and I can
retweet things from here if I were
logged in so now let's go to power and
let's check and see that the form came
back the the email that I sent
so my contact forms right here and I can
modify it here as well but what I really
want to do is see my responses I can see
that I've already received this response
so again just to conclude you can create
dynamic websites in minutes using
nothing more than HTML CSS and power is
the power
I owe tool and you can deploy it
instantly with bit balloon to a real
life place on the Internet you can
actually go to this URL if you want and
check out this website it's live and it
should remain live forever
enjoy